Hey Carmichael
So tomorrow is thanksgiving-
Oh Jesus!
Oh god that scared me!
That- ohhoo...
Yeah, actually
Where you goin'?
Get back over here!
Whoah
I am quite thankful for this vlog actually. At the-(unintelligible)
Making a video every other day,
for a full year,
can stress you out, can push you and
Can really teach you how to get something done and how to work harder and faster to achieve the same goal.
Well, I'm thankful for all you viewers because you allow us to live this ridiculous lifestyle where I get paid to create art and ride
around on electric vehicles like this and just do dumb stuff with my friends and...
I have an outlet where you know,
people can watch it. It's like what more can I ask for? I'm not thankful for Niko, Niko can-
Leave a comment
Saying what you guys are thankful for because I'm actually legitimate curious because we actually read most of the comments
And so if you guys are thankful for anything let us know cuz I might be reading them
I got nothing to do from the next four days, so
type Away!
I have things to do. I have friends.
I don't.
[Bang]
Toy gun.
Hey Wren
That's a dollar
Ow, I realy hit my knee